angry Jumana dayavan tobu note single
Ramudu alibi in the evolution talk about
Lee take a ballerina tiger belly life
juices energy within you without you on
the outside on the inside on the
outskirts on the upper lower register
whoa of your psyche soccer soccer it's
it's haikus it's poetry it's things that
just flow out of me Gunners and I'm
gonna tell you something right now this
Tiger belly situation has really gotten
to my head I'm really peaking even think
that I am this love King like a messiah
no like a demon God even a door a
demigod no demon God oh I didn't we miss
spell it I'm a demon God okay oh god no
I'm a demon God this is Japanese accent
still no I really it's gotten in my head
I uh I I was in San Antonio right I go
up on stage and people yelling nosotros
papaya yeah George is a pink dick slept
King all this stuff and these are and
and then after I meet these people and
I'll do things like I'll touch their
face and go this year is gonna be your
ear and they their eyes get all jiggly
no they vibrate they get jiggly and they
vibrate and they look at me and they go
really yeah and they say nosotros
provider to me and there's something
that happens I was at the airport with a
little Punjab kid opened for me a song
oh he's from Bangla and I can't I don't
know the rest a nickname I don't know
the rest of that England - whatever he's
from there and these two guys they're in
uniform and their military
and they said they were trembling and
they said this little papaya slept gang
you would take a photo and I put my hand
on one of the military guy's chest
listen understand and I said fortune and
he goes and he goes what that's what I
would say yeah yeah and I go you I just
gave you fortune and then he looked at
me he goes thank you like I really did
something and I said $20 because thank
you know he's gonna get $20 of a handle
chest means oh wow it's really getting
into my head I really need to take a
break or something I need to take I need
to take like you know a humility break
because I look in the mirror I don't
even see me anymore what do you see I
see just aura you see like a glow what
color is that it's the color of diabetes
and like kidney disease gosh and my neck
hurts so bad yeah and and then there's a
guy there was a couple of guys in San
Antonio who come every time to San
Antonio to see me and they there are
seven foot nine they both weigh 300
pounds and they're they have gigantism I
don't know what they have like Antonio
Silva yeah but they're always in the
front door like these they talk like
these hey Bay yeah like this where are
they from
I don't know and they take me to coke
tacos yeah so I have gigantism people
and they could crush your eyes giant
they can crush you know gigantism people
dick yeah they could crush you yeah like
Andre did the Giant
[Music]